so outrageous has the state of our
country become the earlier this week it
seemed possible an individual who chose
to go and support the vile creatures
fighting against our own troops in a
heinous and bloody war could be allowed
safe passage home I'm talking of course
about nineteen-year-old Shamima
Begum who traveled to his lamech state
when she was 15 and now wants to come
back to the UK
if you can't see an issue it is he must
either be delusional or have never been
exposed to the horrors of is she's now
reportedly been stripped of a British
citizenship and rightly so I don't care
how old she was when she went how many
children she has lost or how many she is
carrying she decided to go up against
everyone over four years ago and now it
hasn't worked out how she fought it
would she wants before she ends up on
the sticky end of the same kind of
violence
she was happy for others to enjoy to
come home she deserves no sympathy no
money and no help she needs to stay put
and support her regime I imagine you and
many others supported this country's
efforts to deport Abu Qatada
the Jordanian al-qaeda ambassador in
this country who then went back to
Jordan and face trial I imagine people
like you and others who have this view
supported the deportation from this
country of Omar Bakri Mohammad who's
currently in jail in Syria in Lebanon
Lebanon for terrorism offenses and
supporting Isis who was in this country
that known as the top of my attala
colloquially who was in this country for
years as the founder of al margarine the
group that then became Isis and I
imagine you and others who take your
view supported the attempts to deport
hook-hand Abu Hamza who was eventually
extradited to the United States and is
currently in a Supermax for a long time
what has led a lot of the brexit debate
even has been this country's failure to
deport foreign terrorists who came to
this country back to their countries of
origin in those three cases and others
we succeeded in doing so and rightly so
because they were immigrants to this
country who abused the hospitality that
this country provided them so likewise I
find it
quite hypocritical if we take that
policy not to adopt a similar policy and
reciprocate when are terrorists born and
raised in this country with only one
passport British go to foreign countries
and export extremism from here to those
foreign countries they went to Syria
from here and just as we expect other
countries to take foreign terrorists
have come here back we should take our
terrorists back from them when they try
and and deport them here - she's not
under Syrian jurisdiction because those
areas have been liberated from Isis
currently the Syrian regime has no
control over them she's in Kurdish and
Free Syrian Army territory and they
don't have a government to put her on
trial and so I think for that reason
number one we we have to take a bat
because we've done the same that's the
rule so he's a number two yeah I know I
know I understand you're angry but
reason number two it's not about her and
how we feel about her
it's nothing to do with her she's a tone
deaf ungrateful extremist jihadi bride
the problem I have with this is the
legal precedent it sets if we can allow
this government to strip people of their
citizenships who are born and raised
here using national securities of
pretext we end up in George Orwell 1984
territory it's already being used
deportations for criminal charges not
only terrorism and that's the slippery
slope it ends up being the case that
someone like me born and raised there
knows no other country apart from
Britain or June for some future
arbitrary crime yet to be defined the
government now has the power to strip me
of my citizenship for a crime that you
could also commit I get punished twice
and you get punished once and I'm asking
you a question why is it fair to punish
me twice for the same crime that you may
commit or been punished and my other
point to come back on though is she
chose to go over there she did not want
to be British I chose to cuz it's not
about okay it's about the legal
addresses so she her allegiance is
totally to Islamic state who have
claimed they are a state okay all right
whether they've been accepted while the
rest of the world is being a state or
not that's where she chose to be and
that's where she should stay until
they're either completely eliminated or
there's no let's hear from Samina before
we go to June Shamima herself as I said
it's not about her she's an ungrateful
jihadi bride and you can you can watch
this for yourself sex - how she speaks
about I think a lot of people should
have like sympathy towards me for
everything I've been through
you know and I all right I didn't know
why I was going into and I left and I
just was hoping that maybe me a foot
sick of me and my child let me come back
did you know what Islamic state we're
doing when you left for Syria because
they had beheaded people there were
executions those things and I was I was
ok with it after my son died I realized
I had to go for the sake of our children
the sake of my daughter and my baby it
was only at the end it was only at the
end but you didn't have any regrets up
until that point I mean if someone
should be telling her to stop speaking
but but I'm gonna hand over to you but I
just want to say one last thing right
if the Anders Breivik equivalent of that
massacre that happened in Norway that we
all know horrific mass far-right if the
on district equivalent did the same in
Britain he wouldn't get deported because
he'd only have one heritage whereas if
somebody with dual heritage did it
they'd get imprisoned and then deported
that's double jeopardy and it's not fair
and I just want to say everything that
Majid has just said and then the other
piece I would add is actually I think
the safest thing that we could do for
this country is to bring her back and
make sure that she stands trial if we
leave her out there than the amount of
notoriety and fame she now has she has
the opportunity to become the next
Samantha Lake wait where she would
actually be capable with the white widow
capable of actually radicalizing other
brides other young girls and become an
icon for is there's no way we need to
bring her here if she has committed any
atrocities that we can prove make sure
she stands trial put her through a D
radicalization program and also take
control of that child who knows who this
baby is gonna be if we allow them we
leave her there for Isis to them make
her at some sort of icon for the
community no way
isn't the danger I mean I was supposed
to wear to blame for this we
we are because she decided to sugar look
after a man who was over there trust me
I've been over the Syrian people in 10
yards of Isis right and I've seen the
devastation in the hideousness they look
I've seen a woman that was shot twice in
the head right way she was repeatedly
raped in front of her family okay she
sat there and made tea for a man who was
doing stuff like that Nana you stayed
aloft don't find any reason to bring her
back and if she wants to come back the
only thing I could do ever is lock her
up for an extremely long time or not
okay whether she's found guilty or not
for the very fact that she went over
there as a treat that's just treason but
Phil when when I completely beaten you
said and there's no state as you call it
where did she go
what did she go we swept up and interned
with the rest of them over there release
them if we don't take him back yes what
Trampas emotionally I'm with you by the
way I am with you and I don't really I'm
with ya but in terms of what makes sense
but the theory in the plan is I don't
believe our laws are robust enough to
actually deal with her properly if and
when she comes back I would take from
you Michelle I'll take that robust
something that's fine just on the other
than all we got inviting or expressing
support for a proscribed organization
gives you ten years in jail we asked the
Home Office very statement if I move to
the Home Secretary has clearly stated
that his priority is the safety and
security of Britain and the people who
live here in order to protect this
country he has the power to deprive
someone of their British citizenship
where it would not render them stateless
we do not come as an individual cases
but any decisions to deprive individuals
of their citizenship
are based on all available evidence and
not
can lightly now I what I don't
understand this is the what legal advice
has been taken here because he knew well
the home say what you know when you're
the home secretary or your vanity or you
run a big organization tonight you can
take two sorts of legal advice you know
we want is that what the first lot of
legal advice is you say I want someone
who supports well I'm going to do and
the second base of so can't please tell
me what the legal vote the law legal
standing it was to get it was to send a
message to anyone else thinking about
going off to Syria and also to pander to
the right so I will make two points the
first of all we have returning jihadists
roaming around our streets and we
shouldn't have that it's it's just
beyond comprehension
those people should not be allowed so
that's why I worry it's all well and
good you know yeah bring her back and
let's face the the the face of the law
here is this is not going to happen I
don't believe that she came back she
would be locked up for the rest of her
but she would I think so Lisa's
different a high-profile nature of the
her case means that they would have to
find a way to make the law child I think
if you are you know declaring yourself
as a terrorist basically you shouldn't
be able to keep child and that fact the
final point I want to make what I found
interesting of these last few days is
how many people are sitting there saying
oh she was a child she was a child she
was a child while simultaneously saying
these people of the similar age are
adult enough to be able to vote in
completely different circumstances so I
found it so contradictory okay so either
you're a kid you don't are you man to
make it about her and look at the legal
precedent instead